- Saviez-vous qu'en voyageant
de Montréal à Paris en avion,
de CO2!
Mais il est possible de
compenser nos émissions de gas
à effet de serre en achetant
des crédits carbone.yez
une entreprise afin qu'elle
réduise l'émission de GES
en votre
ARNAUD CÔTÉ-BE GES
- Ça m'aide potentiellement
à me se, mais aussi
à avoir un impact moindre.
- Arnaud Côté-Boisvert a pris
l'habituaprès chaque voyage.
ARNAUD CÔTÉ-BOISVERT, voyageur
RMETTE COTE GES
- C'est facile à prévoir.
On peut le budgeter.
générée... il paie une trentaine
de dollars.Carbone Boréal, un pe
associé à l'Université du Québec
à Chicoutimi... plante ensuite
Et la pratique est de plus
en plus populaire.
SYLVIE BOUCHARD, coordonnatrice
Carbone Boréalla pandémie ça no,
mais depuis quelques mois,
depuis janvier on voit
une certaine hausse.
Plusieurmême de même de même der
une compensation lors de l'achat
t d'avion.
Des experts constatent que
en plus conscientisés,
mais aussi que les conséquences
des changements climatiques
sont plus visibles.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS LÉONARD, vice-
t affaires publiques,
- Il y a une réalité qu'on
observe tout le monde... ce
dans lesdans lesdans lesdans le]
C'est des choses qui frappentl'a
une prise de conscience plus
forte des changements
quotidiennes."
Mais attention, les crédits
carbone ne règlent pas tout!
ÉMILE BOISSEAU-BOUVIER, analyste
- Il faut éviter de se dédouaner
avec ça, c'est un outil parmi
tant d'autres et pas la solution
à tout nos problèmes.
L'impact des GES se fait se
En contrepartie, il faut compter
une dizaine d'année pour
que les
ÉMILE BOISSEAU-BOUVIER, analyste
des politi.climatiquesÉquiterre
- C'est comme aller
à la pharmacie et prendre
petits pour nos blessures
et que ça prenait des dizain
d'années pour nous guérir,
on ferait plus attention de pas
de bless
PAULINE ROBERT, direc. marché du
carbone et gestion des GES,
- Compenser c'est en dernier
le maximum et qu'on a évalué
nos différentes options.
- Et lorsqu'on choisitnser, il t
de se tourner vers
eprise fiable.
Les certifications gold standard
et verified carbon standardÉMIÉe
des politiq.climatiquesÉquiterrs
qui s'équivalent, c'est pas tous
les crédits qui sont aussi
s'entendent, vaut mieux réduire
nos émissions de ges
à la base. Limiter
nos déplacements, revoir
nos besoins, et puis finalement,
nos GES.
ICI KV R